[Music]
on the second night of bachelor in
paradise 'as two-part season 4 premiere
viewers saw the cast return to paradise
production had resumed after an
investigation into allegations of
misconduct shut it down Warner Brothers
hired an outside firm to look into
everything that supposedly happened here
they looked at all the video footage
they concluded that there was no
evidence of misconduct by cast on the
set
only Demario Jackson and Kareem elympios
didn't come back and host Chris Harrison
asked contestants to talk about why
production was shut down and what
happened during those days do you think
race played a part in this
unfortunately yes
we didn't think she did anything wrong
and neither did de Mario in current
statement she referred to herself as a
victim why do you think she did that
maybe she just didn't want she wanted to
try and save face was kind of what I
took from it it was a very big statement
and it was left to interpretation by
design
it's unfortunate you also turned the
talk to another difficult subject
consent Harrison essentially asked the
cast to define it how do you know when
someone has given consent when you are
getting intimate with somebody verbal
sentence is like the best way to know
that someone's giving consent so
somebody's passed out unresponsive can
they give consent no no if somebody's
drunk and they give consent not to make
light of the situation but it's like
alcohol clouds your judgment but you
can't give attack ultimately he
requested the group quote keep consent
issues in mind then took a poll asking
if everyone wanted to be a part of the
show again they did credits rolled and
bachelor in paradise began again but
what did you think of how the show
handled the scandal and its fall out
during the premiere episodes how do you
feel about the discussion on consent let
us know over on Twitter
[Music]
you